"The Batman" brings the Riddler to life in
a brutal new way, courtesy of actor Paul Dano,
who gives the villain a sinister edge.
Which brutal act is the worst of the worst?
Caution: spoilers ahead.
"What is the price for your blind eye?"
The Riddler begins as Edward Nashton, a former
resident of an orphanage once run by Thomas
and Martha Wayne, Bruce Wayne's parents.
When Edward and Bruce were children, Thomas
announced his run for mayor of Gotham City.
But he and Martha were killed shortly afterward,
leaving his promises of change unfulfilled.
In the final act of the film, the Riddler
has been captured and incarcerated in Arkham
State Hospital, but has left clues indicating
he has one final act of mayhem planned.
Batman interrogates him and learns that Edward
has held a grudge against him since he was
a child.
When Thomas and Martha Wayne were murdered,
the public's attention was focused entirely
on young Bruce.
This left the orphanage forgotten, whose terrible
living conditions Edward describes to Batman
in painful detail.
While Edward can't be entirely blamed for
feeling jealous of someone who lived in a
mansion while he suffered in a rundown orphanage,
that's no excuse for taking things out on
an entire city.
As part of his plan to bring down Gotham City's
elite and reveal their darkest secrets, the
Riddler cultivates a large online following
that is able to carry out his mission even
in the event of his capture.
He does this by releasing videos of himself
committing crimes and declaring his vengeance
on the corrupt rulers of the city.
This vengeance plays out in full when the
Riddler is incarcerated in Arkham State Hospital.
When he's interrogated by Batman, he reveals
that he has placed car bombs throughout Gotham
City.
The bombs go off, destroying Gotham's breakwater
walls, which causes considerable damage when
the city is flooded.
This upheaval is all part of the Riddler's
scheme: The chaos acts as a distraction, enabling
his cult-like followers to carry out the assassination
of mayor-elect Bella Reál.
However, with the help of Catwoman, Batman
is able to take down the Riddler's "fans"
and prevent the assassination from taking
place.
It's not enough that the Riddler enacts a
large number of heinous acts throughout the
film — he also films them and releases the
footage to "inspire" Gotham City's wayward
minds.
This elevates the Riddler from a common criminal
into a genuine monster.
As mob boss Carmine Falcone's crimes against
the city are exposed, Catwoman vows to kill
Falcone — who is also her estranged father.
She takes off for the Iceberg Lounge with
Batman and Gordon following closely behind.
Once she gets into Falcone's office, Catwoman
points a gun at him — but before she can
fire a fatal shot, Batman stops her.
He turns Falcone over to Gordon and the Gotham
City Police Department.
After he's read his rights, the Penguin pulls
out a gun and prepares to kill Falcone himself.
But then Falcone is shot dead by the Riddler
instead, who's ensconced in a nearby building.
Falcone is no angel, having committed plenty
of crimes all over Gotham City over the course
of decades.
But this is but one of many murders the Riddler
commits throughout the course of the film.
Given that it's simply a kill with a gun actually
makes it one of the tamest.
The worst are yet to come…
"I'm just here to unmask the truth about this
cesspool we call a city."
At the point in time "The Batman" takes place,
James Gordon has not yet risen to the rank
of police commissioner, the role he's most
associated with as a character.
Instead, the commissioner of the Gotham City
Police Department is Pete Savage.
In stark contrast to Gordon's steadfast morality,
Savage is deeply corrupt, having accepted
bribes from various criminals.
Shortly after Mayor Don Mitchell Jr. is killed
by the Riddler, Commissioner Savage holds
a press conference.
He announces the terrible news and promises
to bring the Riddler to justice for his crime.
However, before he can carry out this vow,
he's killed by the Riddler.
The villain leaves a message for Batman and
releases a disturbing video of Savage's death
to the public.
What makes this kill so disturbing is how
Riddler does it — by trapping Savage's head
in a twisted maze with some hungry rats.
Distributing the footage of the killing makes
this an especially cold-blooded crime.
District Attorney Gil Colson is another respected-yet-crooked
member of Gotham City's elite: Batman discovers
early on that he's working for crime boss
Carmine Falcone.
However, this doesn't make his death at the
Riddler's hands any less appalling.
During a funeral service for the late Mayor
Don Mitchell Jr., a car careens into the church
where everyone is gathered.
Out comes Colson, who has a phone attached
to his hand and a bomb attached to his neck.
Bruce Wayne, who is attending the funeral,
leaves, then returns as Batman to talk to
the Riddler via the phone in Colson's hand.
The Riddler threatens to set off the bomb
unless Colson can correctly answer his three
riddles.
With Batman's help, Colson manages to answer
the first two — but he can't bring himself
to answer the third, which would reveal the
informant who helped the Gotham City Police
Department bring down crime boss Salvatore
Maroni.
The Riddler proceeds to detonate the bomb,
killing Colson, and sending Batman flying
backward.
So, let's recap.
The Riddler ruins the funeral service for
the mayor he killed, kidnaps and torments
the district attorney, and then horrifically
murders him.
As if that's not bad enough, he also broadcasts
the event live to his growing online audience.
The Riddler's worst moment is also his first:
Brutally killing the mayor of Gotham City,
Don Mitchell Jr., on Halloween night.
It's a brazen way to kick off his vicious
campaign, and he couldn't have done it in
a more cold-blooded way.
Shortly after watching news coverage of Mitchell's
mayoral debate with Bella Reál, the Riddler
sneaks into his home and viciously beats him
to death.
He leaves Mitchell's body propped up on a
chair with his head wrapped in duct tape,
with the words "NO MORE LIES" scrawled across
his face.
To add to the gruesomeness of this crime,
Mitchell's thumb is removed and later found
attached to a USB drive in his car, giving
new meaning to the phrase "thumb drive."
The drive contains photos of Mitchell with
another woman, revealing that he was having
an affair.
When Batman and Gordon plug the drive in,
it automatically leaks the photos to the media.
He kills the man, and then completely obliterates
his legacy — and, as you may recall, his
funeral — after the fact.
Thanks to the Riddler's cruelty, Mitchell's
wife and child don't just lose him — they
lose their good memories of him too.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.